what's up guys bang bang here's your
weekly update on bitcoin on chain
metrics and the market structure first
let's take a look bitcoin's price is
sitting right around 39 000 that's up
about 10 over the last 24 hours or so as
we've seen russia invade ukraine at
first bitcoin sold off but ultimately
has come roaring back and that 10 gain
is pretty telling about how the global
market is looking at bitcoin in times of
geopolitical uncertainty if we then look
deeper into the actual bitcoin network
what we can see with those statistics so
we're sitting right around 750 billion
dollar market cap 90 of the supply has
already been issued and is in
circulation about 12.9 billion has been
settled on chain the last 24 hours and
miners were paid about 36 million
dollars over the last 24 hours to
actually secure the strongest computing
network in the world the bitcoin network
ultimately bitcoin's down 43 from its
all-time high but it's up about 20 from
its local low and so bitcoin continuing
to do exactly what it was designed to do
produce block after block after block of
transactions no matter what's happening
in the world and that's why bitcoin
continues to work exactly as designed
now if we jump into and look at bitcoin
compared to gold s p 500 nasdaq and tlt
what we can see here is that bitcoin
continues to grow at a compound annual
growth rate of 145
over the last 10 years it is absolutely
incredible it also maintains a 1.5 sharp
ratio which is double gold's and about
double the s p 500. now let's dive into
some of the on-chain metrics and what we
can see on chain or in the market
structure is the open interest you can
see here that since december or so open
interest that's all that leverage had
been growing in size but what we saw on
the far right of this chart is that
since russia invaded ukraine there was
quite a bit of a short squeeze there a
ton of that open interest has fallen off
those were people who had leveraged and
that move upwards that 10 percent gain
wiped out a lot of that interest this
comes from the block where newsletter
which is fantastic will clemente and the
rest of the team looking at some of
these metrics then if we continue and we
look at the supply metrics what we can
see is that about 76.5
of bitcoin supply has not moved in the
last six months it's an all-time high
that blue line just going up and to the
right 76 and a half percent of all of
bitcoin circulating supply has not moved
in at least six months then if we
continue one of the things that i think
is a long-term trend that's really
important to watch is this idea of where
the bitcoin supply resides here willy
woo provided in this chart green that's
that big one that jumps up at the
beginning that is wales people with a
thousand bitcoin or more the pink is the
retail traders and what we saw is back
in 2019 into 2020 that's when retail
overtook the whales retail holds more
bitcoin now than wales and it's only
continuing to head in that direction as
retail gains more and more bitcoin the
whales have less and less within their
control and so ultimately what we're
seeing is that bitcoin it's serving as a
great store of value even in times of
political instability bitcoin is
something that not only has financial
benefit but there's a lot of people in
the ukraine that are either raising
money via bitcoin that avoids any sort
of financial censorship or they're
taking their wealth they're trying to
get it into bitcoin and they're heading
for the border whether it's poland or
elsewhere they want to get out of the
country they want to get out of harm's
way and take care of their families and
bitcoin is a tool to help them do that
hope you enjoyed this quick deep dive on
bitcoin this week and we'll be back at
it again next week with will and the
rest of the team until then have a great
weekend and i'll see you next week